let's imagine that your product looks
amazing everything's working smoothly
the colors are awesome but the revenue
stream is low what what could be the
problem there could be a number of
roadblocks that prevent users from
spending money in your app a roadblock
could be a design issue that discourage
users for example a complex registration
form or user exceptions on particular
devices you can use the reports we've
talked about in the previous lessons to
help you identify the roadblock and more
effectively monetize your users let's
take a look at a few examples that will
help us investigate and find the reasons